[Music]
okay all right we just got done seeing
one called
beach bum that beach ball Matthew
McConaughey Snoop Dogg and Jimmy Buffett
come on all right
this movie is basically kind of like a
modernized slightly upscale version of a
Cheech and Chong flick really just
aimless humor and drug humor and alcohol
humor and kind of like a slice of life
adventure got this dude he's just
totally [ __ ] worthless but he is a
genius he's married this super genius
writer he writes poems and he married
this amazingly rich woman they live over
here in Florida that mocked down in
Miami and it's one of these mansions
right there on the on the bay hanging
out a Snoop Dogg even though Steve dogs
playing and other guys playing himself
but the name that they give it this gray
yeah
and they hang out with Jimmy Buffett's a
bunch of Jamaicans it's it's a
ridiculous movie it there is a message
to it the basic message is don't worry
be happy' kind of good old [ __ ] song
and a shadow worry be heck
he just gets high [ __ ] up from this
weird [ __ ] happened everything and
everything works out yeah he's almost in
a struggle and he doesn't even need his
money doesn't even care about his money
[Music]
octet what do you think in the game I
actually liked it
trailer for this a couple of times and
from the trailer I'm just like I have no
idea what that's gonna be about or what
that's gonna be like it's written and
directed by Harmony Korine which if you
don't know who that is
back in the 90s even kids he did gumbo
joy and monkey boy he did like some
other cut those really weird like indie
movies back in the 90s and he's done
like some more I think he did one
recently called trash humpers which I
have not seen although I've seen clips
of it and it looks so I wasn't really
sure what to expect with this one like I
said I didn't really know what it was
about you can tell from the trailers but
I actually ended up liking this one a
lot more than I thought it's really it's
fun hilarious it's hilarious yeah it's
like cracking up yeah we were just the
situation's thinking of just so we take
your days it's ridiculous but if you
might owns it's ridiculous if you like
Cheech and Chong Lucas you probably like
this one yeah there's a lot of pop you
yeah you do you feel you feel like
you've been drinking or doing some kind
of illicit substance watching it only
thing I the only thing I can gripe about
the movies that after a while I started
to feel like it was out stand its
welcome it started to I started like
reached kind of a point of diminishing
returns where I was like yeah this is
funny but I'm kind of done with this you
know I'm a hurry I'm in the movie yeah
it seemed I think I woulda edited some
of it out it just felt like it was
harping on the same themes over and over
again like it kept harping on the on the
on the life is about fun theme and then
you know the meaning that material
material wealth doesn't mean anything it
harp on that too much I thought I think
I think they should they should have
touched on that in the nation to got
artists some other themes yeah because
not everything that happened to them had
any kind lesson to some of it did but a
lot of it didn't I think a lot of it was
ad-lib to actually it does give that
impression the performances didn't feel
like performances they feel they felt
very it was very natural
yes especially like Snoop Dogg you could
tell he you could tell us new dog was
ad-libbing and just have a fun I mean I
kind of feel like that like on the shoot
of this movie they probably just gave
everyone tons of booze and sons of lead
into said just and just yeah and like
you kind of pushed him in this direction
it doesn't it has applauded it doesn't
the pacing of the plot is a little
strange like yeah felt like the first 20
minutes of the movie then the movie was
aimless and all of a sudden something
happened which I don't want to spoil
that and you go okay so there is a point
to this movie yeah and then from that
methane like yeah yeah but it doesn't
really resolve itself or unfold itself
in any kind of a rhythm you notice that
the pacing is weird everything that it
does is weird like they get around to it
abandoned so I want to think that a lot
of this movie was just ad-lib it does
seem like yeah it seems like if it's
ramshackle but I don't mean that in a
bad way cuz I actually thought it was
really funny like I I'm enjoying it it'd
be much I would have enjoyed it better I
think if I was pretty lucky if I was
drunk I really liked it
yeah so but yeah I you know for what it
is I approve of it and feel like it's
I'm gonna put it into Cheech and Chong
genre i'ma put it right there
you say that yeah and like I said if
you'd like Carmody Koreans other movies
um this isn't as weird as something like
gumbo was or something like that but
this is kind of a little bit of a more
mainstream but it's still not a
mainstream movie but it's not as weird
as this and it kind of shows side to
Florida which exists but I think it was
a little exaggerated you don't see
people we live in Florida you don't see
people walking around smoking joints
that big and you don't see naked women
just walking around everywhere we don't
in Miami but you know I don't think well
you know you don't pick up women to have
sex with amendment in the kitchen of a
restaurant well he does he did but it
was another thing too they were trying
to allude to how his character was so
like over the top of ridiculous but he
got away with it away like you know what
else we know what else are you gonna get
Ian you can't even have sex with women
of all ages super beautiful women just
pick him up there or there and he just
screw an old hag it didn't matter
did he care he's having fun and then he
finds out that his best friend his Snoop
Dogg is banging his wife and he's like
guy that I was alright getting really
care yeah and then they talk about it
yeah your wife's would she'd make the
eye contact with you it's that kind of
[ __ ] it was funny but I could tell they
were had living it yeah I could tell
they did a good job
you
alright this uh toggle washes am yes we
also saw Shazam Shazam is [ __ ] awesome
I would I would I would actually put
this one above Aquaman
I like a light dock I like I like -
Aquaman - but I like this better than
Aquaman if the tone was right everything
that was that everything that is [ __ ]
kinda crazy and silly about superhero
movies they let that be funny yeah then
they just lean into it because it is a
ridiculous it's ridiculous premise all
this [ __ ] a superhero shit's [ __ ]
ridiculous so you might have fun with it
and you just push through it and then
all of a sudden becomes cool sometimes
if you take this [ __ ] too seriously it
to me it it's nerdy a lot of these
Marvel movies kind of to me they seem
kind of nerdy but they're because they
take themselves seriously yeah it's like
come on man you know but with this it's
serious and it's a set and it's kinda
kind of that kind of the kind of a
parody of itself to the point to where
it powers through it yeah and it becomes
cool but it's almost kind of like what I
liked about it like a and I think I
mentioned this on the Aquaman review -
like I said that they leaned it leaned
into the cheesiness yeah they do - they
do that in this one - but in a much more
self-aware - yeah yeah because this is
much less fantasy based it's based in
the real world yeah you know pretty much
all the come out on a ground or
underwater right all the characters are
just like normal people yeah it's like
you know shows am is just this kid that
gets some into the Wizards and he turns
him into a superhero and so he can grow
up and he's 14 year old kid and it goes
down pretty much exactly as you would
expect if a 14 year old kid suddenly
found that they could turn into an adult
superhero yeah I'm on par with Superman
and then well I don't want to spoil
everything Shazam is not really just one
character per se Shazam is more like a
power yeah that can be channeled through
a person yeah and you'll find out more I
don't want to spoil it I also like to
this was a little bit of
origin story for the supervillain you
know he is also and I like that they
kind of started the movie out with that
all the kids in this were great because
you know he's if you've seen the
trailers you know that he's like in a
foster home and stuffs there's like a
bunch of other kids living in the house
I love that the foster dad is Jerry yeah
walking what was good is that the town
oh wait the tone of each scene was
really on point like the [ __ ] that was
funny was funny yeah the [ __ ] was
supposed to be scary was scary there's
some scary [ __ ] yeah there's a lot of
supernatural horror in this that the
villain is basically possessed by seven
demons yeah and and when you see it it's
quite cool and then the fight scenes are
violent and they say [ __ ] killed and
Shazam is kind of like it's a kind of a
Greek patterned kind of superhero the
motifs on the outfits and kind of the
backstory
there's kind of a Greek look to the to
the to the uniform yeah and they take
that [ __ ] lame ass like leotard type
type superhero and they make that look
cool yeah cuz you know to me it's no
armor or anything like that it's like
just a badass [ __ ] in this damn
instant rightfully it's where the white
cape and they they just push through it
until it's cool yeah and I like I said I
like this better knock oh man it was
really really funny
all the characters like all the kids
like all the foster feel like really
really charming and sweet and so what's
funny is that it's a movie about kids
and kids would [ __ ] love this but the
movies quite adult too at the crossover
is perfect the tone is perfect yeah I
think that did a really good job damn
near 50 and I'm [ __ ] loving this [ __ ]
just laugh it was a yes like the theater
that we saw it in was like pretty fact
we said it like four o'clock and
afternoon and when we came out that was
a huge
like yeah let's see the next one I think
this is probably gonna do really well
better than occupy message I feel good
yeah like funny type it's just like a
really charming story everybody's
likable in it and yeah and it's like yes
I am a super likable and he he plays it
exactly right that's exactly what a 14
year old kid and an adult superhero body
would be like yeah he's cracking jokes
and he doesn't know what to do about it
and Kent and his little buddy like his
little sidekick the other foster kid
like from that home that kids hilarious
yeah everything that you would think a
14 year old boy would try to do he tries
it tries to do it in an adult body and
it kind of works not really that really
tries to talk like an adult to adults
and kid yeah I would say DC kicking ass
Pet Sematary of course which is uh it's
an old story it's from Stephen King book
and you know what year did that first
would the would your netbook come out
probably like 81 82 something like that
yeah I'm pretty sure it's because I
remember reading it when I was in this
isn't the first telling of this story
but what they did is they kind of
changed up a lot of stuff in it towards
the end to make it feel like this is the
first time you've seen this movie which
I think was a good decision because
there was a lot of things that happened
towards the end dad were like well it
didn't go that way in the everyw
actually likes the changes the changes
were I was gonna I don't know [ __ ] like
should I say no I can't spoil it because
it's worth seeing
the performances are good the story is
good the writing is pretty good it is a
they did certain things where in in the
Edit and in the storytelling that tie it
in with the shining of course of course
yes yeah so you definitely tell that
this is the same universe as the shining
yeah for second I thought that that it
was Danny Torrance that was the main
character grown up well he did call him
doc yeah what was his name he's a doctor
Louis it was so it wasn't dangerous now
because I'm making that movie later this
year that's good yeah okay but yeah he
was freaking mad with Jennifer yeah I
liked it a lot actually it had like a
really nice creepy atmosphere like I
said the the book of Pet Sematary is
probably my second or third favorite
Stephen King book The Shining is my
first favorite the 1989 I want to say a
version of this that Mary Lambert
directed I actually liked it at the time
but I saw it recently and it has parts
of it really haven't aged all that well
but this movie they pretty much stuck to
like similar story be it's a similar
pace and stuff like that but like I said
they made some kind of significant
changes
not so much to how the plot went but
they you know they kind of switched out
a few things so and I think that was a
good idea because it didn't affect the
story you know in a negative way where
you're like oh gee
or anything like that but it's like it
still made it like a new experience yeah
and if it's psyched you out a couple of
times with the way they did shots of say
like well you know I like the guys back
tendon on the back of his foot
yeah so you can tell like the guys that
made this movie like I said I was
looking forward to this because the two
guys the guys that made this movie I
think they've made several but they also
made one called starry eyes a couple
years ago which is really really good
and I think it's still on Netflix and I
think it's on shutter also and you
should go check that out that's like a
really good surreal story but I like
what they did with this but honestly I
like it better than the original movie
that was made of this it's it's much
more feels much more updated it's a lot
creepier
yeah it's updated in a certain way but
you can also tell because you know the
effects are a lot better and it's really
good but you can also tell that really
what this is as a late seventies early
eighties slow burn or horrible yeah and
you can definitely tell that it is
almost thriller or suspense like gory
moments in it like you know Victor
Pascal getting hit by the car and you
know his brain and everything like that
which yeah which they did in the
original movie but you know it was added
a bunch of stuff of visions and ghosts
and it know it all makes sense you know
when you see it that's that you notice
how like some of the stuff we're ghosts
talking to you in visions remind you of
the shining the book The Shining and the
shine well that was in the book too
right when he got what Victor was
talking to him in the book and you can
tell about the it's a king and it's a
kid it's a Stephen King story definitely
yeah yeah and a lot of it it's taking
the book they just switched around some
things just so it would seem like a new
thing but it's still very much in the
spirit if the original thing and I have
to say I actually really liked that they
did
yeah it's kind of [ __ ] up so uh yeah I
recommend a movie I definitely do too I
thought I thought it was pretty good
good really good adaptation yep
[Music]